I know monsters aren't real but there is
an invasive fish here in the US that
breathes out of the water and walks
across land what the hell is going on
I called Pam fuller and Matt Nelson okay
hello we're here both fish biologists
who study non-indigenous aquatic species
because I want to talk to them about
this straight-up badass fish the proper
name for it is actually northern
snakehead thanks Pam when the northern
snakehead was found on the eastern US
coast in 2002 the media went crazy
because this fish was named one of the
most invasive species to date its
origins are in Asia but scientists
aren't sure how it got here some say it
may have escaped a fish market like
walked off and made it into a nearby
stream where it found a new and suitable
home and this wouldn't have been hard
here's why if you were to make a
successful invasive species checklist
this fish checks every single box
lots of progeny parental care broad
thermal tolerance meaning they make lots
of babies that survive can live almost
anywhere here here and eat almost
anything whatever they can fit in their
mouths they're gonna eat and they can
breathe out of the water how is this
even possible Matt told me northern
snakehead are called obligate air
breathers which means they must breathe
on the surface periodically in order to
survive they have a chamber kind of in
the back of their mouth kind of behind
where the gills are you could think of
it kind of like a very rudimentary lung
not allows this fish to extract oxygen
out of the air and because they can
breathe air they can crawl out of
whatever body of water they're in and
into another where say there might be
more food even if that Trek takes them a
few days
the northern snakehead has a firm hold
in our rivers ecosystems much to the
dismay of ecologists and while fishing
has helped control its populations these
guys are here to stay